joining us here on the rich eisen show
in advance of
a huge wrestlemania event huge for us
here on peacock because it's going to be
streaming live for the first time
exclusively on peacock this saturday and
sunday the 10th and the 11th of april
and on night one
part of wrestlemania 37's monster cart
this man is going to defend the wwe
championship against former champion
drew mcintyre
he is none other than bobby lashley here
on the rich eisen show how are you bobby
hey i'm fantastic man thanks for joining
us here do you have any uh
sense of of is die hard a christmas
movie bobby i didn't think we'd go in
this direction
we just what do you think bobby is die
hard a christmas movie or not what do
you think i
i gotta say it is i gotta say it is i
believe it is i i think that they
they used so much in in it and it was
around the christmas time and everything
there was a lot of christmas stuff that
was involved in the movie so i have to
say it was a christmas movie well thanks
for joining us bobby i appreciate you
calling in here
[Laughter]
how's life for you these days christmas
time not a christmas movie
during christmas well i guess it's i
guess christmas day if you will is
coming for all of us here on peacock as
well as uh
the wwe with wrestlemania 37 being
exclusively on peacock how
how is everything looking down are you
in tampa already at raymond james side
of the super bowl in this year's
wrestlemania are you ready for this yeah
well i'm ready i'm not in tampa yet i'm
actually in denver i just left um
my last training session before i leave
out of the cold and head down to the
warm down in tampa but i am
i'm definitely ready and i'm ready to
head down there and do some business do
some work
well i was in that stadium for the super
bowl and the fact that there were fans
there
um how how often have you wrestled
have you uh performed in front of fans
lately bobby well it's
i think the last it's been a year it's
been about a year
and for us it was kind of challenging
because when the pandemic happened
everything got shut down
we were kind of stuck in the building
and we were doing shows with
no audience at all for some time but
then we after that we
we had the the thunder dome we put the
screens up so the fans were able to log
in and watch us
so then it made it a little different so
it's been okay
but uh we're definitely ready for the
fans to get back
well and that's going to be again on
peacock coming up this weekend how does
how does one go from
missouri valley college to be the naia
national wrestling champion in the 177
pound category as you
were to the wwe walk me through how you
got started on that
journey bobby oh boy that was a long
journey um
i i grew up in kansas my dad was in the
military so we're all over the place i
ended up getting a scholarship to
missouri valley
went up there and um and it was i was
pretty successful down there i took
fourth as a freshman
and then i won nationals my sophomore
junior senior year and 177 went to 184
to 197
and then when i was at the olympic
training center after college
i wrestled at 96 kilos which was 211
pounds
and um i was pretty successful there i
took second to the world championships
military world championships and
and represented the united states army
team
at um world championships and
and for nationals few years and then um
kurt angle which was wrestling in the
wwe
came down to olympic training center
when i was trained
and he and i started talking and he was
like man you got a great look everything
about doing professional wrestling
i was a big fan of kurtz um growing up
anyway from high school
to college and and into the wwe so i was
a fan of his
and i already knew kurt so it was kind
of a big deal that he came to me but he
kind of opened up the door for me to
come in
and um to make a long story short short
um after i met
kurt i was still at the olympic training
center and i was training to make it to
the 2004.
olympics that was my goal and um
on the way through after me and kirk few
months later
i was in a bank the bank got robbed
and these guys came in shooting i took a
dive down to the ground
split my knee open ended my amateur
wrestling career get out here and um
yeah i ended my amateur wrestling career
um because
the i landed on my knee exploded my knee
my knee and i had to
get my burster taken out my meniscus
it just cues damage but
before that a couple months before that
kurt had saw me at the olympic training
center he already passed my number of
all
so after i had surgery
one of the guys from wwe called me up
and i'm sitting there laying on my couch
thinking
i can't believe this happened you know
20 something years of amateur wrestling
this is my main
goal these guys come in shop a bank
ended everything for me i didn't know
what to do i was like what next
sitting on my couch praying i don't know
where i get a call from wwe
they're like hey you know we saw you at
last wrestling tournament kurt spoke
really highly of you
you want to bring you in for a tryout
and
you know i thought it was a joke i
thought this is crazy i'm on my couch
praying
and that i know where this happens um
but then you know i rushed my rehab
and got through went down to the tryout
didn't tell them nothing about
um my knee or anything like that i
wanted to keep that completely quiet
sure because i didn't want them to cut
it out or not give me the opportunity
because of
me so i didn't say anything so i had to
rehab like crazy and and then i was able
to go to the tryout and i was able to
take it through the tryout
i looked good at the tryout they
licensed me at the tryout so they
offered me a contract
so um from then it was all history you
know i came through
and i always tell people you know when i
when i down to wwe wwe's been my olympic
gold medal this wwe championship was my
olympic gold medal because it's at the
top
and that's where i wanted to get and
that's where i trained my whole life for
so when i got into wwe i just you know
just busted my butt
for years and stayed on the grind and
finally i won the wwe championship
and finally i get to main event
wrestlemania um
14 years or 17 years since that date
of the bank robbery no kidding
so yeah i mean i i really skimmed
through the story the story is
really elaborate but i didn't want to go
but my gosh i think
well let's just say you you you hit the
the important details bobby
i mean bobby lashley here on the rich
eisen show so you're saying it's
a combination of of hard work
determination
to succeed in amateur wrestling a chance
encounter with kurt
angle and then then a
random moment in time in which your life
was online because you walked in
a into a bank at the wrong place at the
wrong time
and all together that's part of the
reason why we're going to watch you go
against drew mcintyre
in wrestlemania 37 on peacock saturday
night
essentially it's destiny man it was
destiny
i mean i i remember laying in the bank i
remember laying down on the floor
because because what happened these guys
came into the bank kicked the door down
i was in the i was in the back of the
line and all the tellers were facing
the door and i'm facing the tellers so
when they kicked the door
open the guy automatically went shooting
which was unfortunately right towards
the back of my head but because
everybody was screaming because these
guys were breaking through the door i
had
turned my head to turn around so the
bullet essentially went right over my
shoulder into the wall
and when i went when i saw them i took a
dive down to the ground
so i'm laying down on the ground
thinking
what is going on you know i was thinking
and
it was what went through my mind over
and over again it was like
this is not the way it's supposed to end
you know i kept thinking that over and
over again i'm completely vulnerable
laying out my stomach
on the bank when it's getting robbed and
all i was thinking is
man this is not how it's supposed to end
and remarkably it's
it it was a beginning of of
a remarkable ascent you know not just
physically
off the ground but essentially to
superstardom here
with the wwe i've got bobby lashley here
uh
on the rich eisen show let's uh stick in
the here and now can we can we stir
something up with drew mcintyre you want
to talk some crap smack
whatever you want to do here what do we
got here for saturday night
something that we could we could throw
on a bulletin board or something like
that what do you got for me
bobby well you know me and drew have
history you know
i've beaten you down every chance that
i've gotten he's got a little bit on me
but it hasn't been
the mullen that i've put on him at
several different times and
you know what this is one thing that i
can say everybody in the wrestling
business when they get on top
they look at the guys that they can have
like this i want to have a cool match
with that's how it's been lately i want
to have
a cool match with him because that guy's
really good
you know i came back into wrestling
after some time off
and i and i formed a faction called the
hurt business yes sir
and heard this is a group of guys that
they had the potential to be on top but
didn't want to play the politics didn't
want to play
the pc stuff just wanted to go out and
beat people up
and that's what we've been doing this
entire year so um
this is destiny for me yeah maybe then
wrestlemania
so drew is just merely a stepping stone
for me he's a great champion
and i think drew is going to go down to
history as probably one of the greatest
wwe champions in history
however right now i'm just a different
breed right now
i'm completely unstoppable right now
tj jefferson rich eisen show social
media grand maester
and uh wrestling aficionado uh i give
the floor to you
uh you asked a question of drew when he
was here the last time
uh i give you the floor for a question
of bobby lashley go for it tj
what up champ not too much well so i
have two questions for you bobby uh one
you know my buddy joey granted spent
some time with you in columbia and he
had nothing but great
he had nothing but great things to say
about you and uh he told me to tell you
what up
uh two you mentioned to her business
bobby and we just on screen posted a a
tweet from mvp
that basically said the you and he or
her business and they're always looking
for talented applicants have the day you
deserve and i'm sitting here bobby and i
just want to kind of
pitch myself to you as a member of the
hurt business wearing a t-shirt
i have the hurt business t-shirt right
now live on peacock out to millions
and millions of watchers bobby and you
know my thing is bro like
you're on tv for three hours a day on
monday and then you have all the others
championship stuff that you need to do
but here i am bobby 15 hours a day
unscripted
that i could preach the gospel of her
business for you guys
so what i'm just saying is if you if
you're looking for that applicant i can
be your guy
as a matter of fact you know i took the
check
upon myself to put up some photo
shops and you see there's me you and mvp
uh
you know i and actually i i dm'd you to
your instagram so you can see these
pictures
you know me and her business and also
bobby the her business is all about the
gold right you're a champion you're all
about money
and and and championships yolo yes
so i want to say this bobby uh on this
website wrestle rumble on instagram
last year i won every single nxt
title eight of them bobby so i'm draped
and gold myself i got the nxt
heavyweight championship over here
and there's me you and mvp me with my
eight nxt
belts i got the nxt heavy men's
heavyweight the women's heavyweight bob
you got the cruiserweight
i have the north american i got the tag
team i have the uk
men's and women's asking the question so
bobby lashley what i'm saying is
if you need someone for the hurt
business i think i'm your guy and i want
to put pressure on you i'm going to ask
you for a slow yes instead of a quick no
that's all i'm saying wow wow that was
that was a hell of a pitch and you know
what i usually typically tell people
because people usually pick those
pictures at the wrong time
i'm in the middle of an interview right
now so it's personal time if you call me
on my business you can talk
business all right with all that package
call me on my other line my business
line we can sit down we can have a
discussion about it
i'd like that right off the bat i got to
say your pitch was
quite impressive thank you sir we're
always looking for people that like to
strive for that gold so i will
definitely keep you in mind so when you
do
call me on my business line then we can
discuss this you're all about
business i'm with you i'm all about well
let me just quickly jump in here bobby
he is trying to help brand you this is
kind of business in a way yeah this is
your personal time but he's helping
brand you
on this show and as the man whose name
is
on the show he's got his name on coffee
cups i'm more than
happy to lend this platform
to tj on behalf of joining your hurt
business
so i'm i'm now if you will coming in
top rope on top
to try and pin this thing down for you
tj i appreciate that what just something
to think about bobby just something what
do you think
man well i get i gotta tell you with a
reference like that
um um i think we might be able to do i
got to give mvp a call but i'm sure
he'll probably be on the more positive
side
and i think we might be able to do some
business all right like i said i know we
got to run it by p
but i'm okay and one last thing bobby
gosh
one last thing i just want to ask you
this question about
there's a guy that all of us want to see
you in the ring with and it's brock
lesnar
and i'm just wondering even if it
doesn't happen in the wwe ring
are you willing to take that to dana
white or scott coker and we could see
this in the ufc
or bellator cage you and brock lesnar i
don't
i don't really think that it's a case of
of
finding a venue to do it because
i'm sure vince would i'm sure scott
would i'm sure dana would i'm sure
anybody would want
to host that fight it's just brock it's
him
it's him i'm prepared i'm ready uh his
brock
and his um his people um whenever they
think that it's it's necessary whenever
they think it's a big enough deal
then i think that they will go and step
up and i think at that point
um it'll happen i'm sure you know right
now my loyalty is to the wwe
but um i've been a fighter my entire
life
so i don't care where it is i just think
it needs to happen for the fans
so um i think that's the question that
you need to post towards brock because i
think that uh
he says yes we can do it anywhere nice
bobby
thanks for the time thanks for the call
uh let's do this more often
and um congrats on all your success
and best of luck this weekend on on
wrestlemania we'll be watching right
here on peacock
thank you i appreciate you you got a
safe journey that's uh
bobby lashley at fight bobby on twitter
bobby lashley on instagram what a story
what a night it will be on saturday
night
that's just the first night of the two
day
wrestlemania 37 event that's going down
at
raymond james stadium super bowl 55.
now here comes wrestlemania 37
exclusively right here
on peacock hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here